[Music]
The amount of white miso sugar and mirin that should have been used was kept to the bare minimum to emphasize Amami due to the bending, and
instead, the amount of yuzu juice was increased to strengthen
the sourness.  I added a bitterness and astringency.The
balance of the taste is balanced only on the condition that I ate the beef loin of the 3 seniors first
.  In the course, the first
dish is served first, and then the second main dish is served to bring the customer's expectations to the climax.
In
other words, I used Star Eizan's description
as the opening
act.  From the beginning, I was
sure from the time the theme was decided that if my
senior used arch chalk, it would be
a hindrance to tourism and Amami.  There were some ingredients that could be used,
for example, a miracle fruit that makes a sour taste sweeter
, but the substance called miraculin contained in it lasts for about two hours.
I observed your state and continued to trace
your
thoughts.  Have you been observing me since the beginning
of the aether?
I think I'm
going to do that. I'm going to continue cooking archi chalk as it is. I don't know that I'm being watched
.